[Music]
thank you very much thank you all for
coming
this is me with my
son sammy
a little while ago so in this talk i'm
going to be talking about how technology
might affect two different parts of
parenting so
the conception early years of childhood
so this sort of biological infancy stage
where biology
you know really rules
and then the educational years so more
the social formation bit now obviously
biology is still being affected
by what we do in our education it
affects us in our bodies but we're going
to be talking but we think about it more
as as where we've got more option to
form us with our ideas and our education
systems
so
my own background is actually in
environmental philosophy more and
environmental history but i moved into
bioethics so
what i'm not is a scientist so we're
going to
have a little dive where we need to know
sufficiently in this science that's
affecting us but i can't answer any of
your deep questions about how the
science works you'll have to go to
ganesh taylor's talks
on that here we're going to talk more
overview about what's what's on the
horizon which in our ethics sort of work
that's what we do we have to scan
roughly what's going to affect us and
think about how how we can approach it
so the first thing we sort of have to
think about as parents is what what
actually are we
so
i like to think about us a little bit as
fruiting bodies so as you know with a
mushroom
the
organism is actually under the surface
you have the mycelium under the surface
and the odd thing about us is if we can
think about how we reproduce as an
organism
what we can see is kind of like the
fruiting body so
with a bit that is noticed by another of
our kind and we meet and we reproduce
and we have babies but the interesting
question about us and how it affects the
technologies affect us and how they
affect our value system is what's our
mycelium type thing is it our genome
is it our value systems what's the
invisible part of us
that we are the fruiting body of so this
an idea that's going to recur
so what kind of parents are we
biologically so there's lots of
different parent-child models across
nature
and some are not so great
even when they're super cute so for
instance here we've got black bears if
they only have one child they will
abandon the child because it's so high
energy to do the work of parenting in
the early stages
that they just think surely worth the
effort so the tension between
the adult and the baby
they're just like maybe not not going to
do this they want a larger brood
now with and that's to do with their
environment so you know
patchiness of prey energy costs all of
that kind of thing now with the pandas
with the pandas
they
will abandon
and focus just on the ones so they do
intensive
um focusing just on one child so high
intensive high focused parenting
basically because their bamboo that you
can see in the background is really poor
in nutrients so
in for them they're kind of parenting
models straps on basically
i've got a stronger baby here so i'm
going to focus on that one
so different you know what what affects
us i mean we are actually still very
affected by biology in our parenting in
lots of different kinds of ways
we are still affected by energy like
them
and resources
there are lots of different kinds of
parent-child models around the world
but always
you know how much it takes out of
parents can i have a hand in the air for
anyone who's a parent in this room
keep your hands in the air if it's
blooming hard work
yeah we feel that energy and it affects
us but we also do know there are all
kinds of ways our biology still affects
us for instance you know if there's
if you're biologically related to your
child if you're not biologically related
to the child in households higher risk
of abuse for instance puberty onset can
be earlier in female
children if there's a non-related male
in the household so our biology actually
still affects us and we're going to look
at the ways in which technology is
really kind of intruding on that
so lots of different parenting norms and
models this is the classical world this
is i think this one's on i'm not
absolutely sure where this is from i
think this is luxor in egypt and you can
see the mum's
i think breastfeeding her baby while
fiddling about with figs doing some sort
of work
she's basically multitasking back in
ancient egypt
what i was saying to you about the way
that biology still affects us
you know
in the past in terms of what we thought
was the best way
to be a parent
if you were very affluent in classical
egypt in ancient egypt for instance you
would often have a wet nurse to do the
breastfeeding whereas if you were from a
poorer family you would certainly you
know breastfeeding your own child
probably be breastfeeding other people's
children
throughout a lot of the kind of early
stages of parenting in human history
predominantly
learning takes place through proximity
and pursuing the tasks that that your
father or mother have done and usually
through observation and that still
affects us now we'll come on to that a
little bit later but
we actually still learn slightly better
through physical observation and gesture
even really abstract things like
mathematics
we actually learn better through
physical enactment and through
observation so someone writing on a
blackboard for instance would make a
difference
but obviously we're now here at the
automated parenting
you know we've had lots of different
ways of interacting with what we think
is best for our children so in classical
greece for instance they kind of thought
you weren't really a legal person until
you were accepted into the family in a
kind of formal sense
and we
we can't go back and absolutely ask
everybody but the evidence is you know
that
children in some sorts of rights as
infants would be left
on a rock to kind of survive if they
made it through the night they would be
accepted into the family
and then they would become a legal
person who we would then think about
educating and entering them into the
policy into the kind of wider society
society
all the way through these different
parenting norms though we're still
always balancing those energy and
the questions of energy uh that all
organisms face today
though
we live in really really unprecedented
times so we're still all of these
ancient difficulties that we face
are now being influenced by
technologies that most of us sort of
little understand so i said at the
opener didn't i that i kind of
i'm not a scientist
in the work that i do in bioethics i'll
be faced with really complex
new frontier technologies
most of us even on that committee don't
really understand them
and yet we have to somehow decide how
they're going to affect us as parents we
have to somehow make choices about how
we allow new technologies to influence
the becoming of our child right at
conception through to how we educate
them is a very difficult time and at the
moment it's just kind of creeping in
without
any of us
understanding the implications or really
knowing how we can make choices about
them
so we'll look at the first part of it so
two different parts to
parenting as i said the kind of first
heavily biological bit so how do we make
our babies
in denmark in 2003
they made prenatal screening for down
syndrome available to any parent who
wanted to
have it now the screening is pretty
pretty good but obviously it's not going
to perfectly
guarantee
that your baby would definitely have
downs or not
but what they found
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas